hey youtubers it's Charlie so the big
news is is that Batman vs Superman is
gonna get a home video release that has
an r-rated version of the movie
now they'll still be releasing the pg-13
movie they're releasing in theaters we
need to talk about what that means so I
thought it'd be fun to do like a Batman
Kills video just all the times Batman
has killed someone
Superman has killed people - it seems
like r-rated superhero movies are
suddenly in vogue now because Deadpool
was so successful not every movie is
gonna be Deadpool but there's the idea
that the Wolverine movie is gonna be
rated R because they're doing old man
Logan and that's probably the most
hardcore Wolverine story that I've ever
read and I think the R rating for Batman
V Superman over the pg-13 just implies
that it's gonna be really intense what
does that mean well go and watch the
Adam West Batman then read Frank
Miller's Dark Knight Returns when your
brain explodes that the idea of an
r-rated superhero film really you know I
think it's just gonna be a slightly more
hardcore version of Dark Knight usually
as the Joker that you talk about killing
people but Batman is actually killed
quite a few people which is why we need
to talk about his top kills surprise
surprise 1980s Batman kills KGB's this
was the same eras Frank Miller's Dark
Knight Returns comics are hardcore
Batman's hardcore so he kills cagey
beasts after he attempted to kill
President Reagan knowing that if he were
to let him be captured by authorities
he'd be able to use the justice system
to escape so Batman goes Edgar Allan Poe
walls him up in a sealed room and just
waits for him to die way back in the 30s
and 40s when Batman was a relatively new
character he killed a ton of gangsters
in a bunch of different ways it treated
it in an offhanded way but when you
really look at it killing someone is
killing someone no matter how the comic
treats it in Batman number 1 in 1940
people always talk about this kill just
because it's so WTF he hung a mentally
ill patient from a rope and flew around
in the batplane till he died he's kicked
people into car grinders he kicked a
villain into another villain sword to be
fair a lot of these 1940 stories or war
propaganda that he killed a cart full of
Japanese by throwing a weapon into its
spokes also an example of Batman who
uses guns maybe not in the way they were
originally intended but he's still using
a gun he's killed a whole bunch of
people in traffic accidents Frank Miller
back at it again during all-star Batman
and Superman has Batman incinerate a
villain with a mall table cocktail it
does not happen
quickly it takes a long time to burn to
death during Christopher Nolan's Batman
Begins he leaves ratio ghoul to die in
the train crash the way they played it
is Batman is definitely leaving Rachele
ghoul to his fate to die in this
horrible crash you also look at the
Michael Keaton Batman films he pushes
the Joker off the cathedral ledge with a
giant weight tied around his ankle yeah
he definitely meant for him to die he
blew up the axis chemicals building when
a bunch of people were still inside and
during Batman Returns the sequel to that
first Michael Keaton film he kills a
couple people one with the exhaust from
the Batmobile
the other was when he sticked a bomb
down the strong man's pants and just
leaves him to blow up so plenty of movie
kills way more in the comics obviously
and probably the most iconic comic book
Batman kills moment that I can think of
this is open to debate but killing the
Joker at the end of The Killing Joke
done in an ambiguous way as if a
thirteen-year-old could read the book
but if you're reading the actual context
of the scene yeah he definitely killed
the Joker you get the idea though there
are a lot of times when Batman takes
down villains in a way that if you treat
it as if it's happening in the real
world that villain would die horribly so
whatever this r-rated cut of the Batman
V Superman film looks like it's probably
just going to treat a lot of those
takedowns and more realistic ways more
broken bones some implied kills in the
past I don't expect anyone to actually
be killed in the movie I think that
they'll talk about people dying during
the Kryptonian attack but dying because
of the disasters that were caused not
because Batman and Superman walked out
to someone and splattered their brains
all over the pavement so let me know in
the comments what do you guys think
about r-rated Batman V Superman does
they get you more excited are you
worried about that and what is your
favorite Batman kill from the comics or
the movies it could be from anywhere but
you know you talk to like 10 different
comic book creators and each one will
have a slightly different take on what
Batman and Superman do and what they
don't do free Miller now and more
they're just the most extreme examples
like taking those characters and
characters like them especially in the
case of Alan Moore analogs of Justice
League characters to their logical
extreme but when you really think about
it I don't you know I don't think that
DC would ever release a film that you
could not take a family to see so if you
have small children you'll totally be
able to take them to see Batman vs
Superman
it's not like Deadpool where there's a
ton of TNA and stuff that you definitely
have to explain to an eight-year-old but
yet be careful if you're taking an
eight-year-old to a hardcore pg-13 movie
you
still probably have to explain a lot of
stuff I think the first hard are film I
ever saw was predator on VHS or maybe it
was HBO it was when HBO was a brand new
thing and it was the reason why when my
mom caught me watching predator on HBO
she made my dad cancel it
in related superhero news not quite as
hardcore but just as awesome vixen is
coming to arrow be sure to watch the
episode she is going to wreck everyone
then tomorrow on legends of tomorrow
they're doing a flash-forward we're
gonna see connor hawke we're gonna see a
future version of Deathstroke that I
think might be Jericho maybe Grant
Wilson I mean it depends on which son of
Slade Wilson they go with white guys
wait for that video to post tonight you
can click here for my flash video from
last night so much awesome zoom and king
shark stuff and you can click here for
the Justice League teaser that Zack
Snyder just dropped thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight